it has been a bit of a dictatorship here
with fur and our you know it's either
her way or not her way Miranda is a
control freak she is involved in
everything she will not release a
relinquish control ever she's not a
people person she has no people skills
she just screams out demand and she's
very rude at times now there is such a
turnover what staff that I don't even
know their names in eight months I've
probably seen over 50 people go
some people come in for one shift and
they listen to her for five minutes and
they roll right out the door I wish I
had two clones of me and believe me this
place would be happy I feel that Brooke
might have to become like the
laughingstock of Midtown
so the repetition around town is that
you know no non so they called me the
crazy lady which is fine to me
you know what if I'm crazy because I'm
trying to save the business so be it
I think we're at that point blur this is
really our last chance if we don't
figure something out it's either solid
get rid of it because we can't sustain
it
[Music]
before I came to town I heard that brick
hotel had a high turnover rate so I had
my team reach out to former employees so
I can get some information before
checking in first of all good morning
I've never met such a large team of ex
employees this is a small showing oh
yeah what there's more
how much turnover is there with staff
been through almost fifteen managers 15
50 miles or 50 I'm the biggest problem
with the place is what ruined our she's
been caught but I watched her and she's
she's mean and she can be a bully in
I've seen her reduced people to tears
wow that's terrible you know there's so
much neglect between not only the staff
through managers but her customers as
well seriously I couldn't take it
anymore I worked the holiday season and
it was kind of like the last straw for
me I won't made you quit I worked all of
those parties through the whole month of
December I was lucky to receive some
payback like in February with your tips
yeah she'll cut you a check in six weeks
when she feels like it she wouldn't let
you go pick up your paycheck she saw the
cops on you you said she called the cops
on you seriously call the police because
you wanted your money yes you're
threatened yeah seriously I mean it
sounds like a dictatorship as opposed to
a boss that's there to support people
loved it there it was very homey the
opposite of now all the locals came we
had a booming hotel business Wow
it was such a great place and then the
quality just steadily went downhill and
I think she had a complete lack of
respect for the staff and didn't
understand that your staff is a huge
asset what a mess
please have you met her I know at least
I just arrived
I'm scurriers just by the way you were
speaking because I thought he hasn't met
her yet has he no no no so calling the
cops
you know high staff turnover standards
dropping I haven't got much confidence
however I'm gonna tackle it head-on
we don't look very optimistic dude thank
you wish me luck
thank you take care